Jean 3,16
Car Dieu a tant aimé le monde qu'il a donné son Fils unique,
afin que quiconque croit en lui ne périsse point,
mais qu'il ait la vie éternelle.
Jean 3,16 est de loin le verset le plus populaire de la Bible.
Il est à la fois cité et connu par des chrétiens et des non-chrétiens.
Il est même difficile dans une conversation de parler de l'amour de Dieu,
de ce qu'est l'amour de Dieu,
et de ne pas dégainer ce verset devant son interlocuteur.
Dieu a tant aimé le monde.
Dans le milieu évangélique, ce verset est ressenti souvent comme une carte maîtresse,
que l'on sort dans un débat sur le salut.
Cela donne le sentiment d'avoir fait échec et maths au jeu d'échec,
ou un kems au jeu de cartes.
Et on le fait devant le méchant calviniste, très souvent,
ou ceux qui soutiennent les doctrines de la grâce.
Toutefois, frères et soeurs, on peut louer la popularité de ce verset,
car il est le meilleur résumé de ce qu'est l'évangile de Jésus-Christ en une seule phrase.
Cependant, il est aussi un des versets les plus mal compris.
Il est souvent utilisé dans un sens qui n'est pas toujours conforme à l'enseignement orthodoxe des Écritures.
En effet, pour une génération qui se caractérise par des slogans tout faits,
et dans un milieu évangélique qui délaisse l'étude sérieuse des Écritures,
il n'est pas étonnant de constater une déformation du sens de ce verset.
Certains vont donc réduire tout ce que les Écritures enseignent sur ce qu'est le salut biblique à Jean 3,16.
Pour ces personnes, il y a peut-être peu d'intérêt à creuser la parole de Dieu
et de s'émerveiller de l'infinie richesse du grand amour que Dieu a manifesté en Jésus-Christ.
C'est triste de le dire, mais en agissant ainsi,
nous avons raté de présenter dans la clarté et de manière biblique
ce que l'Évangile de Jésus-Christ est.
Oui, c'est paradoxal de le dire,
mais Jean 3,16 est à la fois très connu et rarement vraiment compris.
Alors, que faire ?
Devons-nous ignorer ce que Jésus enseigne ici à Nicodème ?
Surtout lorsqu'il dit,
Dieu a tant aimé le monde qu'il a donné son Fils unique
afin que quiconque croit ne périsse point,
mais qu'il ait la vie éternelle.
Non, à l'instar de notre Seigneur,
nous devons revenir à la révélation de Dieu.
Jésus expose cette vérité devant un pharisien zélé pour la loi de Dieu.
Nicodème est un chef religieux.
Il est censé être le docteur d'Israël.
Nicodème pensait probablement,
comme beaucoup de Juifs,
que les desseins et de la miséricorde de Dieu
étaient réservés uniquement au peuple juif,
le peuple élu de Dieu.
Il pensait probablement que le Messie
viendrait uniquement pour le bénéfice
de la nation juive.
Mais mes frères et sœurs,
c'est seulement en revenant au contexte biblique
que nous pouvons comprendre au mieux
ces choses célestes.
Car les paroles du Christ nous interpellent ce matin.
Si vous ne croyez pas
quand je vous ai parlé des choses terrestres,
comment croirez-vous
quand je vous parlerai des choses célestes?
Jean 3, verset 12.
C'est l'occasion de s'arrêter
sur l'une des déclarations les plus glorieuses,
les plus magistrales,
les plus belles des Écritures
pour nous assurer d'avoir bien compris
ce qu'enseigne notre Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Et surtout,
surtout pas juste comprendre,
mais afin d'y obéir.
Afin d'y obéir.
Car il serait tellement triste
d'agir par négligence
et de ne pas prendre Jésus au monde.
Nous allons donc pour ce faire
exposer la vérité centrale de ce texte
qui est
la manifestation de l'amour transcendant
du seul vrai Dieu
envers un monde déchu.
La manifestation
de l'amour extraordinaire
d'un Dieu
dans une seule catégorie
avec qui il ne partage
même pas cette catégorie
envers un monde rebelle,
déchu,
pécheur.
Nous allons donc pour ce faire
et avec un souci
d'exposer nos cœurs
à une écoute intelligente des Écritures
parler en premier moment
de la révélation
de l'amour de Dieu.
Puis en deuxième partie,
nous verrons la foi en Christ
comme réponse de l'homme
et surtout
en tant que don de Dieu.
Et enfin,
nous terminerons notre exposé
de Jean 3,16
avec le fruit de la foi en Christ.
Mais juste avant de commencer
cette première partie,
j'aimerais que l'on se rappelle
une vérité capitale.
Elle est vraiment capitale,
cette vérité.
Nous ne pouvons pas essayer
de connaître Dieu
en projetant sur lui
ce que nous sommes.
Je voudrais dire par là
que nous ne devons pas prendre
l'amour humain
comme référence
et en déduire
que l'amour de Dieu
lui est comparable.
Ce serait une grande erreur
car Dieu n'est pas seulement
quantitativement
et qualitativement
différent de nous.
Il est aussi
cuiditativement
différent de nous.
Cela veut dire
que dans son essence même,
il est différent de nous.
D'une manière si profonde
que nous ne pouvons imaginer.
Il n'est pas comme nous.
Nous sommes des créatures
et lui le créateur.
Dieu est autre que nous.
Il n'y a aucun comme lui.
Son essence est divine
et la nôtre ne l'est pas.
Ainsi,
la vie,
l'amour,
la bonté
et toutes les réalités
de cet ordre
ne peuvent être attribuées
à Dieu
et à l'homme
de manière univoque.
Pas plus que ne peut l'être
leur essence.
La vie
et l'amour de Dieu
diffèrent des nôtres
autant que son être
diffère du nôtre.
Comprenez-vous
un peu mieux
la différence
entre qui Dieu est
et qui nous sommes?
Il existe
dans une catégorie
tout autre.
dans son essence même.
En tant que
cette créature,
notre rôle
n'est pas de mettre
Dieu sur le banc
des accusés.
Notre rôle
n'est pas d'être
les juges de Dieu.
Notre rôle,
c'est de l'adorer.
Et c'est pour cela
que nous avons été créés.
C'est pour cela
que nous avons été
rachetés
par le sang de Christ.
C'est pour cela
que nous sommes venus
au culte d'adoration.
alors par l'exposition
de sa parole
de manière fidèle,
je voudrais
que nous puissions
l'adorer
comme nous l'avons
commencé à le faire
par les chants,
par les prières,
par l'exposition,
au travail
de nos offrandes
et maintenant
au travail
de l'exposition
de la parole de Dieu.
Abordons donc
la première partie
de notre prédication
avec la révélation
de l'amour de Dieu.
Car Dieu a tant aimé
le monde
qu'il a donné
son Fils unique.
Ces mots
de notre Seigneur
sont prononcés
dans un contexte
d'échange théologique
avec Nicodème.
Après avoir révélé
le cœur troublé
du pécheur,
le Seigneur lui expose
la merveilleuse doctrine
de la nouvelle naissance.
Pour Jésus,
c'est la condition
sine qua non
pour entrer au ciel.
C'est la condition
pour voir
le royaume de Dieu.
Nicodème,
qui est le docteur
d'Israël,
est désabusé
comme laisse entrevoir
ses questions à Jésus.
En face de l'enseignant
par excellence,
Nicodème comprend
que sa connaissance
de l'œuvre
du salut de Dieu
est défaillante.
Toutefois,
Jésus,
le vrai berger
d'Israël,
ne l'abandonne pas
à son ignorance.
Mais il se donne
le soin
de le conduire
à contempler
ce qu'il appelle
lui-même
les choses célestes.
qui est mieux
que Jésus
pour le faire ?
Qui d'autre
que le fils
de l'homme
pour exposer
l'œuvre du salut ?
Personne n'est monté
au ciel
si ce n'est
celui qui est
descendu du ciel.
Oui,
personne
si ce n'est
le fils
de l'homme,
Jésus-Christ.
Jésus va donc
employer
les vérités
de la Bible
de Nicodème
pour le conduire
à contempler
de manière
plus claire
la délivrance
préparée par Dieu
depuis les temps
anciens.
une délivrance
que Dieu
ne s'était plus
à en donner
des ombres
avec Moïse
lorsqu'il éleva
le serpent
dans le désert.
Et c'est à ce moment
particulier,
Frère de Sœur,
de cette discussion
que notre Seigneur
expose le cœur,
la source
d'où l'on peut
entrevoir
la résolution
d'un Dieu saint
à sauver
non des amis
mais
des ennemis.
En outre,
Jésus ne fait pas
que révéler
l'amour de Dieu
comme la source
du salut
que Dieu veut afficher
au temps marqué
mais il veut aussi
pointer
à l'intensité
de cet amour.
Dieu
a
tant
aimé.
C'est un amour
tellement profond,
tellement profond
qui est le destinataire
de cet
extraordinaire
amour,
c'est-à-dire
le monde.
Le monde
est le destinataire
de cet amour.
lui,
mais chers,
ne nous y trompons pas.
Ce n'est pas
un monde beau,
aimable,
doux
et humble
que Dieu a aimé
avec une telle
intensité.
C'est tout
le contraire.
C'est un monde
rebelle.
caractérisé
par sa cruauté,
par sa méchanceté
et par son
idolâtrie.
Un monde
qui manifeste
constamment
sa haine
envers le seul
vrai Dieu
et qui n'attend
qu'une seule chose
s'il le pouvait,
de se saisir
de ce Dieu-là
et de le crucifier.
de l'exposer
à l'ignominie
totale
de manière publique.
Regardez,
il y a 2000 ans
derrière,
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé?
C'est un monde
qui ne boit
que l'iniquité
et qui ne respire
que le péché.
Voilà le destinataire
de l'amour
de Dieu.
Et ce n'est pas
comme si Dieu
a juste aimé
ce monde.
Mais Jésus
nous dit
que Dieu
l'a tant
aimé.
Le salmiste
va nous dire
que l'éternel
est bon
envers tous les hommes
et plein
de tendresse
pour toutes
les créatures.
Somme 145
verset 9
Cet amour
que Dieu
nous a manifesté
est un amour
d'une intensité
et d'une profondeur
dont aucune
de nos mesures
ne pourrait
la quantifier.
Un prédicateur
disait
Combien contient
ce temps
T-A-N-T
Aucune langue
ou intelligence
humaine
ne peut l'exprimer.
Rien ne le décrit
mieux que l'œuvre
elle-même.
Mes frères et sœurs
Cet amour
a la taille
et la mesure
de Jésus-Christ
vraiment Dieu
et vraiment homme.
Un amour
a coupé le souffle
et a réduit
au silence
les actes
les plus inimaginables
d'héroïs
jamais vus
que les êtres humains
pourraient réaliser.
Appeliez-vous
un tout petit peu
ce que Christ
nous révèle ici
l'intensité
de l'amour
de Dieu
envers un monde
déchu
un monde péché.
Toutes les paroles
de Jésus
sont précieuses
mes frères et sœurs
et l'on s'en rend
bien compte
lorsqu'il nous dévoile
comment Dieu
a manifesté
cet amour
envers un monde déchu.
Dieu l'a manifesté
en donnant
son Fils
unique.
Je sais que vous avez
déjà entendu
quelqu'un donner
cette illustration.
L'on aurait pu
imaginer
que des anges
ou d'autres êtres
proposent à Dieu
un plan de rachat
pour un monde pécheur.
Mais qui oserait
s'approcher de Dieu
et lui proposer
de donner son propre Fils?
Qui aurait osé
demander à Dieu
de donner son Fils
unique
pour ses ennemis?
Je vous en supplie
frères et sœurs
réfléchissons bien.
Qui oserait
faire ce pas
en avant
en ouvrant
juste la bouche
et prononçant
nous voulons
que tu donnes
ton Fils
unique
pour tes ennemis?
Qui aurait osé
fait cela?
Devant le Dieu
Saint?
Les Écritures
nous enseignent
qu'à peine
mourrait-on
pour un juste
quelqu'un peut-être
mourrait-il
pour un homme
de bien.
Mais Dieu
prouve son amour
envers une race
méchante
par le don
de ce qu'il a
de plus cher.
Non en prenant
conseil
avec d'autres,
non en trouvant
une motivation
en dehors de lui,
mais en donnant
son propre Fils
par amour
pour un monde
rebelle
et déchu.
Il n'en avait
pas un autre
pour le remplacer,
mais il a
offert son Fils
unique
pour ses ennemis.
Il a offert
à un monde
pécheur
et déchu,
à un monde
rebelle
et méchant.
Jean Calvin
dira
« Christ a
apporté la vie
parce que
le Père Céleste
aime la race humaine
et désire
qu'elle ne périsse pas. »
Et comme tout
ce que Dieu
nous donne
est parfait,
Jacques nous
confirme en disant
« Toute grâce
excellente
et tout don
parfait
descendent
d'en haut
du Père
des Lumières
chez lesquels
il n'y a
ni changement
ni âme
de variation. »
Christ
est le résumé
glorieux
de ce don
qui descend
du Père
des Lumières,
ce don excellent.
Il est le parfait
rédempteur
pour accomplir
l'œuvre
d'expiation
suffisante
pour tous.
Il est parfait
pour offrir
une rédemption
assez vaste
pour tous.
Il est vraiment
le don de Dieu
comme il a mentionné
à la femme
samaritaine.
Si tu connaissais
le don
de Dieu
et qui est
celui
qui te dit
Donne-moi
à boire!
Tu lui aurais
toi-même
demandé
à boire
et il t'aurait
donné
l'eau
de vie.
Jean 4,
verset 10
Mes frères
et sœurs,
Nicodème
n'est pas
le seul
qui a besoin
d'être
corrigé
sur l'extraordinaire
amour
de Dieu
manifesté
à des pécheurs.
Mais nous aussi,
nous en avons besoin.
Car c'est en nous éméveillant
devant l'intensité
de cet amour
et de ce don
de Dieu
que nous serons
résolus
à lui faire confiance.
Nous serons
enclins
à persévérer,
à courir
dans cette carrière
qui nous est
ouverte.
et même
lorsque
les nuages,
les péripéties,
les difficultés,
les soucis
de la vie
seront sur nos têtes.
Si Dieu
n'a point
épargner
son propre
Fils,
mais nous
l'a livré
pour nous tous,
comment ne nous donnera-t-il
pas aussi
toutes choses
avec lui
mes bien-aimés?
Mais pour vous
qui êtes encore
négligents
du don de Dieu,
vous qui m'entendez
et qui écoutez ma voix
et qui êtes négligents
du don de Dieu,
tournez vos regards
sur la manifestation
d'une telle
intensité d'amour.
Tournez vos regards
sur le Fils
percé à la croix
du Calvin.
Nous vous en supplions.
Nous vous en supplions,
tournez vos regards
vers ce Christ.
Contemplez
son Fils
unique
qui est le parfait
sauveur,
qui prend les péchés
de ceux
qui se confient
en lui.
Dieu ne peut pas
se jouer de vous.
C'est impossible
qu'il agisse
de la sorte.
C'est impossible
qu'il vous regarde
ainsi
et vous méprise.
Tournez
vers vous
vers son Fils.
Il est le don
de Dieu,
doux et humble
de cœur.
Et si Dieu
a aimé ce monde
malgré sa rébellion,
en vous donnant
une offre de salut,
ne la méprisez pas.
Nous vous supplions,
Ne la méprisez
surtout pas.
oui,
ce don est offert
à quiconque
croit en lui.
Alors,
qu'est-ce que Jésus
voulait communiquer
à Nicodème
par ces mots ?
Quiconque croit
en lui.
Après avoir parlé
de la révélation
de l'amour
de Dieu,
dans cette deuxième partie,
nous aborderons
la foi en Christ
comme réponse
exigée de Dieu
aux hommes
et surtout
comme don
de Dieu.
Pour nous aider,
rappelons-nous
du contexte
historique
immédiat
de l'époque.
Nicodème
était un leader
juif.
Il était
inscrit
dans la loi
de Dieu
et des grandes
œuvres de Yahweh
envers Israël.
Il savait
que Dieu
avait choisi
le peuple juif.
Il leur avait
confié
ses oracles
et leur avait
donné
de grandes
promesses.
Nicodème
connaissait
la fidélité
de Dieu.
Israël
avait été
libéré
de l'esclavage
en Égypte.
Israël
avait vu
ses ennemis
chassés
et la terre
promise
lui est attribuée.
Nicodème
s'attendait
donc
à la réalisation
de la plus
grande promesse
du seul
vrai Dieu,
le Messie,
loin de Dieu.
Pourtant,
les paroles
de Jésus
viennent bouleverser
sa conception
du Messie.
Quiconque
croit.
on pourrait
s'imaginer
une hypothétique
pensée
dans le cœur
de Nicodème
lorsqu'il a
entendu
ces mots
de Jésus
quiconque
croit.
Il aurait pu
se dire
quoi ?
Le libérateur
d'Israël
ne vient-il pas
exclusivement
pour la nation
choisie,
pour le peuple
élu ?
Quiconque
croit
inclut-il
aussi
les Romains
qui nous
persécutent,
asservissent ?
Quiconque
croit
inclut-il
aussi
les Samaritains
qui rendent
un culte
infidèle
à Dieu,
au seul
vrai Dieu ?
Quiconque
croit
inclut-il
aussi
les Égyptiens
qui nous ont
mis en esclavage
pendant 400 ans ?
Et bien
que cela soit
hypothétique,
nous ne devions
pas être surpris.
Rappelez-vous
du pharisien
qui debout
au temple
disait en
priant lui-même
« Oh Dieu,
je te rends grâce
de ce que je ne suis
pas comme le reste
des hommes,
qui sont ravisseurs,
injustes,
adultères
ou même
comme ce publicain. »
Jésus
par ses paroles
dépasse cette vision
étroite
et présente
une offre de salut
à tous les hommes
sans exception.
Juifs,
non-juifs,
il n'y a pas
de distinction.
L'amour
de Dieu
est offert
et quiconque
mettra sa confiance
en la provision
de Dieu,
en sera au bénéfice.
Voilà ce que
Jésus dit à Nicodème.
Tous les hommes
sur la terre
peuvent recevoir
l'amour de Dieu
manifesté
en Jésus-Christ
à condition
de placer
leur confiance
dans le Messie
de Dieu.
Jean Calvin
explique
Christ a employé
le terme
universel
quiconque
afin d'inviter
sans distinction
tous à participer
à la vie
et d'enlever
toute excuse
aux incrédules.
Tel est aussi
le sens du mot
monde.
Bien qu'il n'y ait
rien dans le monde
qui soit digne
de la faveur de Dieu,
il se montre
cependant
réconcilié
envers le monde
entier
lorsqu'il invite
tous les hommes
sans exception
à la foi
en Christ.
Cette extraordinaire
vérité
s'oppose
donc à l'universalisme
qui affirme
que tous
sont sauvés
même sans
la foi
en Christ.
La Bible
est claire.
La foi
en Christ
est une exigence
pour le salut
de quiconque
croit.
L'apôtre Paul
va le dire
de cette manière
à Athènes
au milieu
de non-juifs.
Sans tenir compte
des temps
d'ignorance,
Dieu annonce
maintenant
à tous les êtres
humains
partout
où ils se trouvent
qu'ils doivent
changer d'attitude
parce qu'il a fixé
un jour
où il jugera
le monde
avec justice
par l'homme
qu'il a désigné.
Il en a donné
à tous
une preuve certaine
en le ressuscitant.
à 17.
Et cet homme,
c'est Jésus-Christ.
À ce stade,
mes chers,
j'aimerais ouvrir
une grande parenthèse.
Car oui,
il est vrai,
l'Écriture exige
une réponse
de l'homme
devant l'offre
de la grâce de Dieu.
Toutefois,
cela n'est pas
contraire au fait
que l'homme
ne puisse pas
répondre
de sa propre
initiative
à cet homme.
Pour la simple raison
que l'homme
est mort
dans son péché
et que sa nature
pécheresse
est inimitié
contre Dieu.
Dieu n'abaisse pas
ses standards
de justice.
Ce n'est pas
Dieu qui a changé,
c'est l'homme
qui est devenu péché.
et bien qu'il ne soit
plus capable
de choisir
son bien éternel
qui est Dieu,
Dieu ne modifie
pas ses exigences
pour satisfaire
le cœur
des péchants.
Non.
Mais Dieu continue
à atteindre
ses exigences
et à le faire
devant tout homme
sans exception.
rappelons-nous,
les hommes ne choisissent
pas le Christ
biblique
et j'insiste bien,
le Christ
des Écritures,
non seulement
parce qu'ils n'ont
pas la capacité
de le faire,
mais aussi parce qu'ils
n'ont pas la volonté,
ils n'en ont pas
le désir,
aucun,
aucune capacité,
aucun désir
de choisir
Christ d'eux-mêmes.
Toutefois,
Dieu pourvoit
à ce qu'il commande.
Un jour,
le moine Pélage
est tombé
sur les confessions
de Saint Augustin
dans lesquelles
il y avait une prière.
Et dans cette prière,
Augustin supplia Dieu
de donner
ce qu'il commande
et de commander
ce qu'il veut.
Pélage trouva
intolérable
la formulation
d'Augustin
car il pensait
qu'elle jumignait
la liberté humaine
et faisait de l'homme
un simple instrument
entre les mains
de Dieu.
Mais Augustin
d'Ipone
exprimait
plutôt cette formulation,
par cette formulation,
pardon,
l'idée que Dieu
qui ordonne
à l'homme
de faire le bien
donne aussi
la grâce
et la capacité
de l'accomplir.
Car c'est Dieu
qui produit
en vous
le faire
et le vouloir
selon son bon plaisir.
Philippiens 2, 13
Alors,
puisque Dieu
exige la foi
en Jésus-Christ
pour être sauvé,
Dieu
souverainement
et ultimement
est le seul
qui fournit
la foi salvatrice
pour remplir
cette exigence.
Et l'homme
n'est pas
un instrument.
Il a la responsabilité
de croire.
Dieu lui commande
Et Dieu
vous commande
ce matin
de croire.
De croire
en Christ.
De mettre
votre confiance
en lui.
Il est le seul
qui peut sauver,
qui peut vous sauver
de vos péchés.
Qui peut vous sauver
de vous-même.
De vos iniquités
et de la colère
de Dieu à venir.
Il vous ordonne
de croire en lui.
Que vous ne sortiez
pas de cette salle
sans examiner cela
dans votre cœur.
C'est un ordre
de Dieu
au travers de la bouche
d'une poussière
comme moi.
Docteur Sproul
le disait ainsi.
La foi
qui sauve
est véritablement
votre foi.
mais ne vient
pas de vous.
C'est un don
de Dieu.
Je ferme
cette grande parenthèse
et je reviens
à ce que nous étions
en train de dire
auparavant.
La parole
de Dieu
définit donc
Jésus
comme le seul
objet de cette foi
qui sauve.
Ainsi,
Jean 3, 18
appuie avec force
et clarté
cette vérité.
Celui qui croit
en lui
n'est point jugé
mais celui
qui ne croit pas
est déjà jugé
parce qu'il
n'a pas cru
au nom du
Fils unique
de Dieu.
Le salut
dont parle
Jésus
à Nicodème
est en lui.
C'est dans
le Messie,
le Christ
de Dieu.
Ce n'est pas
une sème
croyance
intellectuelle.
C'est une
croyance
de cœur,
une croyance
de la volonté.
c'est une croyance
en sa personne,
en son œuvre
car il n'y a
sous le ciel
aucun autre nom
qui nous a été donné
parmi les hommes
par lesquels
nous devions être
sauvés.
Aucun autre.
Il n'y a pas
un autre sauveur.
Vous n'en
n'aurez pas
d'autres.
Il n'y aura
pas 15.
Personne ne se
trouvera devant
Dieu et dira
tu n'as pas
amené à
7 sauveurs.
15,
13,
12,
24,
etc.
Il n'y a qu'un seul
Jésus Christ.
Lorsqu'une personne
sentant son besoin
désespéré
à cause du péché
se réfugie en Christ
et se confie en lui
s'appuie chez lui
et remet entièrement
son âme
entre ses mains
comme sauveur
et rédempteur
cette personne
est dite
comme le texte
nous le dit
croire en lui.
C'est la
manifestation
de quelqu'un
qui a mis
sa confiance
en Jésus Christ.
Auditeurs
bien-aimés,
ne nous laissons pas
séduire
par les sirènes
des doctrines
sans fondement
qui se veulent
attrayantes
pour des cœurs
de prouvé
d'intelligence.
Regardez à quoi
que ce soit
d'autre
que Christ crucifié,
si saint que soit
l'objet regardé,
ne peut sauver
le péché.
Faisons confiance
à la parole
sûre de Dieu
car quiconque
croit en Christ
est certainement
sauvé.
Ce Christ
est digne
de confiance
et ne mettra
jamais dehors
celui qui se
tourne vers lui.
Jean 7, verset 50 à 51.
Et eu parmi
les juifs
quelques-uns
qui voulaient
le faire mourir.
Et Nicodème
qui était venu
de nuit
vers Jésus
et qui était
l'un d'entre eux
leur dit
« Notre loi
condamne-t-elle
un homme
avant qu'on l'entende
et qu'on sache
ce qu'il a fait ? »
Jean 19, verset 39
Après cela
Joseph d'Arimaté
qui était
disciple de Jésus
demanda à Pilate
le corps de Jésus.
Nicodème
vint aussi
apportant
un mélange
de myrrhe
et d'alouesse.
Nicodème
est bienvenu
à Jésus
de nuit
et Nicodème
n'est pas
resté le même.
Ce n'est plus
la nuit
que Nicodème
apparaît
dans le récit
biblique
mais c'est
durant le jour.
Ce n'est plus
en cachette
que Nicodème
se présente
c'est publiquement.
Qu'en est-il
de vous
qui hésitez
à venir à Christ ?
Vous connaissez
pourtant le chemin.
Jésus
est le chemin.
Il est la vérité.
Il est cette vie
dont vous avez besoin
et cette vie
que vous n'avez pas aussi.
allez à lui.
Courez vers lui.
Jetez-vous sur lui.
Car
quiconque croit
en Christ
est véritablement
sauvé.
Et c'est ce que
nous allons voir
maintenant
en parlant des fruits
de ce salut
qui sont inestimables.
Nous avons abordé
en première partie
la révélation
de l'amour de Dieu.
Puis en deuxième partie
la foi en Christ
comme réponse
de l'homme
et surtout
don de Dieu.
Maintenant,
dans cette troisième partie,
nous allons exposer
les fruits
du salut
du Christ.
Et vous l'avez entendu
en introduction,
notre frère
Nathaniel
a exposé
d'une manière
succincte
cette bénédiction
incroyable
sortie de l'enfer
pour rentrer
au paradis.
Reprenons le verset
pour mieux
s'en rendre compte.
Car
Dieu a tant aimé
le monde
qu'il a donné
son Fils unique
afin que
quiconque croit
en lui
ne périsse point,
mais qu'il ait
la vie éternelle.
Lorsque nous pensons
à la foi
en Jésus-Christ,
nous devons nous rappeler
que cette foi
est l'instrument
par lequel
nous nous accroupions
l'objet
de notre salut
qui est la personne
et l'œuvre
de Jésus-Christ.
Ce n'est donc pas
la foi
qui sauve
met le Christ
en qui
la foi
se confie.
La foi
tend les bras
pour recevoir
un Christ
complet
de qui
découle
tous
ses bienfaits.
En d'autres termes,
c'est par notre union
à ce Christ
Seigneur
et Sauveur
que nous recevons
les innombrables
bienfaits
que sa vie
et sa mort
ont acquis
pour nous.
Et la foi
fait partie
des bienfaits
que Christ
a aussi acquis
par son œuvre
de rédemption.
La foi
est possible
parce que
Christ est mort
pour les pécheurs.
Ce n'est pas
un don
qui est détaché
de Christ.
Ainsi,
aucun bienfait
ne nous parvient
en dehors
de sa personne.
Voilà pourquoi
croire
est ultimement
un don
de Dieu.
L'apôtre Paul
va le dire
ainsi.
Car il vous a été
fait la grâce
de croire
par rapport
à Christ
et non seulement
de souffrir
aussi pour lui.
Il vous a été fait
la grâce
de croire.
Faveur
que nous ne
méritons pas.
la foi,
le fait
de ne pas
périr
et la vie éternelle
font partie
de ce fruit
béni
qui descend
de Christ.
l'expression
ne périsse point
et qu'ils aient
la vie éternelle
traduisent
des aspects
extraordinaires
du salut
biblique.
Les apprécier
nous poussent
à coup sûr
à s'émerveiller
de l'indescriptible
œuvre de Christ
réalisée à la croix.
À s'émerveiller
devant l'amour
inestimable
que Dieu
a manifesté
envers nous,
un monde pécheur.
En effet,
pendu au bois
à notre place,
Christ a reçu
le châtiment
que méritait
nos offenses.
Tous nos péchés
passés,
présents,
futurs
ont été déversés
sur lui.
Ils ont été
condensés
sur sa personne.
Celui qui n'a
point connu
le péché,
il a fait
devenir péché.
il a bu
la coupe
remplie
de nos iniquités
sans qu'aucune goutte
ne soit versée
à terre.
La peine
que nous méritions
à cause du mépris
du caractère
de Dieu
et de sa loi
est retombée
sur lui.
Esaïe dit,
c'est pas
ces maîtres
ici que vous êtes guéris.
Christ a péri
sur l'infâme
bois
à cause
de nos péchés.
Et désormais,
ceux qui sont
unis à lui
par la foi
au Fils de Dieu
ne peuvent plus
périr.
À cause
de ce qu'il a fait
à la croix
du calvaire,
jamais plus
ses frères
ne goûteront
à une once
de la colère
de Dieu.
Jamais plus.
Car quand nous étions
encore sans force,
Christ est mort
pour des pécheurs.
il est venu chercher
ses frères
dans la salle
d'exécution
de la prison
et il les a
tous faits sortis.
Il les a tous.
Un jour,
lorsque nous regarderons
en arrière,
en direction
de cette salle
d'exécution,
nous verrons
qu'il n'y aura
aucun,
aucun de ceux
qui ont mis
leur confiance en Christ
dans cette salle.
n'y aura même pas
un seul cheveu.
Grâce à son œuvre
et à sa personne,
pas un homme
qui a cru en lui
ne périra
sous le jugement
de Dieu.
Aucun ne boira
la coupe
de la colère
de Dieu
versée sans mélange.
Mes frères et sœurs,
lorsque nous méditons
sur la mort
de Christ,
nous pouvons avoir
une plus grande,
en tout cas,
nous essayons
d'avoir une plus
grande compréhension
de ce que Péry
veut signifier.
Nous comprenons
d'une certaine manière
et c'est vrai
faiblement
ce que Christ
a pris à notre place.
Et bien que nous
ne goûterons jamais
à ce châtiment,
nous ne pouvons
banaliser
ce qu'est ce châtiment.
Nous ne pouvons pas
jouer
à le mépriser.
Mais gloire à Dieu,
Christ nous a délivré
de l'enfer.
Toutefois,
Jésus n'annonce pas
seulement à Nicodème
qu'une échappatoire
est possible en son nom,
que le pardon
est juste accordé.
Jésus lui annonce
un salut complet.
Un salut
qui ne consiste pas
seulement à échapper
à l'enfer,
mais à entrer
dans le paradis
de Dieu lui-même.
C'est ce que
Nathalie nous a rappelé
en introduction.
Frère et soeur,
en Christ,
nous ne sommes pas seulement
soustraits de la mort éternelle,
mais nous sommes aussi
conduits envers le paradis
en recevant
par les mérites de Christ
le droit d'être
citoyen du ciel.
Notre patrie
est céleste.
Nous sommes des pélérins
sur cette terre
à cause des mérites
de Christ.
Dieu nous offre
une vie de qualité
en sa présence bénie.
Et nous avons la promesse
que jamais cela ne changera.
Christ communique
une vie
dont l'éternité
ne peut en être dissociée.
Il ne donne pas
une vie pour un moment,
mais pour l'éternité.
Elle ne commence pas
après la mort
de ceux qui ont mis
leur confiance en lui.
Elle débute maintenant.
Et rien ne peut la détruire.
Elle est éternelle.
Elle ne connaîtra
jamais de fin.
Voyez-vous
la valeur inestimable
de ces deux fruits ?
Ils ont été acquis
par le chef,
le capitaine
de nos âmes,
Jésus,
le fils de Dieu.
C'est notre grand frère
qui s'est levé
et qui est allé
à notre rescousse,
qui nous a sauvés.
Il est revenu
avec tous à la maison
et aucun ne restera derrière.
C'est notre grand frère.
Comment ne pas louer
la générosité
de notre Dieu ?
Il n'y a vraiment
pas un autre comme lui.
Il est digne.
Il est digne d'adoration.
Il est digne de louange.
Il ne lait pas
le péché,
les circonstances,
les choses de la vie
nous faire croire
qu'il ne mérite pas
d'être adoré
même lorsque nous traversons
les moments difficiles.
Il est digne
d'adoration,
de louange.
contemplant juste
ce qu'il a fait.
Le prédicateur
Jesse Ryan
dit
On a justement remarqué
que l'Ancien Testament
promettait généralement
la longueur des jours.
Mais l'Évangile promet
la vie éternelle.
Voilà le salut chrétien.
Voilà l'espérance
à laquelle nous sommes destinés.
Elle est sûre
et ferme
en l'œuvre de Christ.
au profondeur
de la richesse,
de la sagesse
et de la science de Dieu.
Que ses jugements
sont insondables
et ses voies
incompréhensibles
disait Paul.
Et nous ce matin
nous pouvons le dire aussi.
Christ est vraiment
le don parfait de Dieu
pour quiconque croit,
pour quiconque
met sa confiance en lui.
Pour finir
frères et sœurs,
je voudrais que pour nous,
Jean 3,16
ne soit pas comme
un simple écriteau
sur nos murs
ou sur nos t-shirts.
Je voudrais que
Jean 3,16
soit placardé
dans nos cœurs
et que nous
tressayons de joie
à chaque fois
que nous entendons.
Dieu a tant aimé
le monde
qu'il a donné
son Fils unis
afin que
quiconque croit
ne périsse point,
ne périsse jamais,
mais qu'il ait
une communion
éternelle
avec Dieu.
Ce verset
est plus
qu'un slogan.
C'est l'expression
de l'amour divin,
l'expression
de l'amour
d'un Dieu saint
à une race déchue.
un amour
que nous ne pouvons
trouver en aucun autre,
en aucun semblable
à nous,
si ce n'est
à celui
qui existe
dans une essence
différente
de la nôtre.
Rappelez-vous,
mes frères et sœurs,
ce que je vous ai dit
en introduction
de cette prédication.
Dieu n'est pas seulement
qualitativement
et quantitativement
différent de nous.
il n'est aussi
quantitativement,
c'est-à-dire
dans son essence même,
dans son être même,
il est différent de nous.
Et quand nous contemplons
Jean 3,16,
nous pouvons nous en rendre compte
qu'il est différent de nous
dans son être.
Alors,
lorsque les circonstances
de la vie
vous feront douter
de l'amour de Dieu,
mes chers,
rappelez-vous
que Dieu a aimé
un monde si mauvais
qu'il a manifesté
un amour immense
pour l'aimer tout court
et bien plus encore
pour l'aimer
en donnant son Fils unique,
Jésus-Christ.
Terminons avec ces mots
de l'apôtre Jean
dans sa première épître
au chapitre 4
et au verset 9.
L'amour de Dieu
a été manifesté
envers nous
en ce que Dieu
nous a envoyé
son Fils unique
dans le monde
afin que nous vivions
par lui.
Amen.
Sous-titrage